27 años después del genocidio de ruanda
un grupo de historiadores franceses
publicó un informe afirmando que francia
tiene una responsabilidad abrumadora en
el genocidio las autoridades francesas
apoyaron al régimen que era racista
corrupto y violento se afirma en el
informe basándose en el argumento de que
los rebeldes tutsis eran una amenaza
para los hutus
el gobierno francés armó y entrenó a
estos últimos estados que los
consideraba sus aliados
las autoridades francesas instalaron
políticas que estaban completamente
desconectadas de la realidad estaban
basadas en divisiones étnicas y ese
acercamiento empeoró la crisis
el informe denuncia la ceguera de
francia ante las preparaciones del
genocidio en 2019 france24 emitió el
testimonio del antiguo jefe de la
cooperación militar en ruanda dijo que
él había alertado a sus superiores sobre
el inminente riesgo de genocidio pero
francia no hizo nada entre varios puntos
del informe destaca el hecho de que
francia se negara a arrestar a los
líderes futuro cuando entraron en una
zona segura creada para las víctimas
comandante francés surgió a parís el
permiso para detenerlos pero el
presidente francés se negó tal y como
explicó el antiguo jefe de su oficina
las naciones unidos nos dieron un
mandato humanitario no uno judicial no
estábamos trabajando para una corte y
ruanda acusó a francia de complicidad en
el genocidio pero el informe de los
historiadores franceses dice que ningún
archivo corrobora esta teoría